so i'm rachel andrew um i'm a technical
writer here at google
um i'm also a css working group member
and i've been sort of working with and
and on css for for a very long time my
own career as a web developer started
before css was a thing
so um i was building sites when it when
it was just html was what you had to use
so so i've been doing css for a very
long time
um and i'm generally very interested in
in layout um as as a subject and
and all the kind of cool new stuff that
we've we've got in layout so that's what
i'm going to go through today we've only
got 90 minutes so it's a bit of a fly
through of
a flexbox and grid
and and with code examples which you
know if you're using codepen you can
fork the examples and and code along
with me which i think is probably the
best way to learn css is actually to
write some css
and
i'll leave the page up
afterwards so you can always refer back
to the examples i was using
um
you can ask questions here in the in the
messages
we don't have a huge amount of time for
questions so if you want to ask
questions in the discord i've put the
link
um on the page there uh it means that i
can go back later today and and actually
answer the questions that maybe we don't
get time to do so it's up to you but if
you want to
if you've got something that you you'd
like an answer to and we might not get
to it then if you pop it in the discord
i shall try and get get in there later
and answer some of those questions that
you have
so we'll get going and we'll get going
with the first example here because
we're going to start talking about grid
so for grid layout um we define a grid
using a value of display so so good
layout is essentially a value of the
display property and we need to do that
on a containing element so here i've got
in my html i've got a container with
with some items it's just a just a bunch
of divs
so on my container which is my parent
i can say display grid
and that's going to give me a good
layout although nothing is going to
apparently happen straight away because
we basically get a one column grid which
looks very much like block layout so
we'll need to start creating some
columns to be able to to see anything
so we do that with the grid template
columns property and for now let's just
create some columns using
some pixels nice and straight forward so
good temperate columns and i've created
three column tracks and you can see that
immediately we end up getting something
that looks like a grid and the child
items all move themselves into into that
into the place on the grid using auto
placement
if you wanted some rows you can do the
same thing so we can use grid template
rows
and for now let's just again give them a
sort of fixed height
as you can see there that we've also
created some rows
um grids are made up of grid lines
they start
from one and at the start of the grid
and that relates to the writing mode of
the document so i'm in english so line
one is on the left if i was working in
arabic which is a script that's written
right to left then line one would be on
the right so it follows the the writing
mode
of the document
now the space between two lines is
referred to as a track so you've got
column tracks and you've got row tracks
we can also have gaps
if we use the gap property
and that will space out your your tracks
essentially
you can also use row gap and column gap
if you want to do those
individually and the smallest section of
the grid is referred to as a grid cell
and that's conceptually like a table
cell really um it's it's the smallest
area that you've got on your grid
another bit of terminology is we have
something called the explicit grid which
is the grid that you've defined with
good template columns and grid template
rows
but you'll find that if you remove the
row tracks and we saw that an issue and
just did columns
you're still going to get
rows and that's because we have
something called the implicit grid
rather than just kind of like stacking
your content up in the corner if you say
display grid and don't define rows or
columns
grid is going to create you implicit
tracks and actually in reality a lot of
the time what you want to do is control
the columns but all you want is the rows
to be as big as the content is which is
what you get by default because tracks
are sized as auto by default
and also it's a bit more complex than
that but generally you can think of it
as being big enough to fit the content
so if you don't define your rows they're
just going to be big enough to fit the
content that you've put in
so that's the sort of basics of just
creating your initial grid um i've used
pixels there to set out my grid but you
can use all sorts of different sizing
methods so you can use any valid length
unit which means that you could for
instance use
m's there
and size your track that way
you could use ch which is
roughly 15 characters
so any of the the length units that
you've got in css you can use those
you can also use percentages
if you use a percentage
for example
20
that is going to be a percentage of the
grid container um that's your that's
your percentage sizing um percentages
are also valid for the gap property you
can use percentages there
as i mentioned you can also use auto for
your track sizing
and that will that would be roughly big
enough to fit the content
the thing about auto size tracks is they
will stretch by default so if we set our
final track there to auto
and there's some extra space in the grid
container you can see how it gets big
and it stretches actually past the size
of the content because it's just taking
up all of the space um only auto tracks
will do will do that of the sort of
standard um
sort of track sizing and the others if
you say 150 pixels you'll get 150 pixels
it won't stretch out to fill up any
spare space if you say auto it will use
as much space it needs to lay out the
content but if there's some spare space
left over it will stretch and fill it
an auto
is
essentially a kind of intrinsic sizing
and what we mean by intrinsic sizing is
sizing that looks at the content and
works out how big it needs to be
um
whereas all the other kinds of sizing
the length units and so on we refer to
as extrinsic sizing as in
you've defined the size and you have
you're going to fit your content into it
um
extreme intrinsic sizing actually says
well i want this to be big enough to to
fit my content
so as well as auto
you'll find there are some keywords that
we can use in
grid layout which actually sort of use
this intrinsic sizing
and also kind of expose a bit how it
works so the first of those is min
content
if i create
three tracks of min content size
you can see how min content behaves
the track that's got the the the seller
that's got a lot of content in it
it's compressed down and what it's done
is it's got as small as it possibly can
do without causing any overflow
which means that it's taking all of the
soft wrapping opportunities it's got
and and getting as small as it can but
nothing's poking out of the box
and so that's that tracks min content
size that's as small as it can possibly
be
so we have the the sort of reverse of
that which is max content
so if we make our tracks max content
size
you can see what happens there so our
cell here that's got a lot of content in
it's
stretched out and it's it's gone as long
as it can but no bigger it's not like
when i used auto and it's stretched
bigger than the size of the content it's
just gone to the size of the content
now that would happen even if there
wasn't enough space for it to do that so
it could cause an overflow for example
um if you had you know a long paragraph
in there it would just keep on
unraveling um and would eventually cause
a scroll bar or break out of your box so
what have you
but that's the max content size um and
that's kind of important to understand
because
although we can use these keywords um as
sizing you know within grid
they're also how grid and also flexbox
kind of work out how big things are they
look at what's the smallest size it can
be and what's the biggest size it can be
and then make decisions about how to
layout your content
based on those two things
so it's kind of
they're kind of useful um
useful sort of keywords to understand um
because they expose something about
about css and how sizing is calculated
but a very useful keyword which uses
this this um intrinsic sizing is fit
content and what fit content does
is we pass in
a value so a length unit
so if we create three tracks using fit
content 10m
you can see that the first two tracks
have just gone to their max content size
they've not gone to 10m because they
don't need 10m to display what they've
got in there
the last track has started to go to max
content size but once it's hit 10m it's
then started to wrap so that's quite a
useful
little function to use on track sizing
because you can
kind of get some of the benefits of
letting things be
sized by content but you're putting
limits on it so you don't say get an
overflow or what have you
it's worth noting these keywords aren't
just defined for grid layout
it's just that they have best support in
grid layout at the moment they are
defined and some of them work better
than others in different browsers just
for things like you know width or what
have you so actually used instead of a
length unit
so they are defined to be used all over
css it's just at the moment um their
best support is in grid and they're
supported wherever grid is supported so
that's that's kind of pretty much
everywhere
but these functions should be available
for for all types of of layout
so those are those keywords and as i say
remember particularly min content and
max content kind of just hold that in in
your mind because it'll it'll come in
useful later when we look at flexbox
we also have the fr unit
now this is specific to grid layout
um it because what it does is it defines
a fraction of the available space in the
container
it's not purely all of the space in the
container so it's not oh you know the
three one fr columns will not give you
essentially a third because if there's
something big in one of those um
good cells
say an image that couldn't that didn't
size down that would still take up more
space and then what was distributed
would be what's left over so it's not
quite um a fraction of the of the whole
space it's of the available space but
most of the time as you can see here we
do get that sort of equal
looking layout um and you can play
around with these values so you can say
well i'd like my first one to have
two fr
and the others to have one fr each
unlike using percentages
the um the gap is taken away before the
space is distributed so
you know you don't have to kind of work
out like we do when we use percentages
for layout
how much uh how much has to go for the
gap
you can also mix fr units and
other length units
again what happens is
the
um
sort of fixed size is taken away first
and then whatever left is going to be
distributed to those tracks
as i mentioned
1fr isn't quite
sort of equal size tracks
and there's a way of making it so if we
just if we just scrunch up this content
here you can
kind of see what happens
so we're making this one so it's um not
going to break
you can see that it's what it starts to
do is it starts to um make that track
larger so they're now not nice and equal
looking because the fr unit is
distributing um the available space
if you want
to force that
you absolutely want that track to be a
fraction of the available space
then we can use the min max function for
our track sizing
and you can see now that that that
string is overflowing and it's it's
overflowing because we've said
we want our tracks to be a minimum size
of zero and a maximum of one fr and what
that's basically doing is saying these
tracks have got no intrinsic size so
that min content max content intrinsic
sizing we're basically saying ignore
that
act as if the track has nothing in it no
content
and then distribute everything
so one fr is actually min max auto 1fr
it's saying look at the auto size of the
track
and then distribute whatever's left
if you
definitely want your tracks to be
absolutely you know sort of in this case
a third of the available space in in the
container you can use min max
01fr and that will
that will sort out the issue
and the reason about when to do that is
if you're doing like a 12 column grid
and you're going to be spanning your
items over track so you're going to be
controlling um how much space
um then then it will work and as you see
if once you go back to broken content
um it all just works itself out because
it's then wrapping and it's fitting into
the track
so if we stay here
and just look at a bit more things about
doing um sort of your track listing
if you've got say if you did have a 12
column grid
and we're using things like min max
that's going to start looking very
verbose so we can use repeat notation to
tidy that up
so if we say repeat
three and then whatever you want to
repeat
and that basically means that you don't
have to write out every single
size sort of track as you go so that
could be anything
that could be you know a set of
exercise tracks if you wanted
um anything you like
and you can repeat um
a single thing like this so you can
repeat um
a pattern in which case
you'll get multiple tracks so here we
end up with six tracks um going 200
pixels 100 pixels 200 pixels 100 pixels
along until you've you've sort of got
the three sets
um you can also use repeat for part of
your track listing
so here we might have our repeating
section
and then 100 pixel track on the end
so you don't have to use it for the full
thing
but it's just a handy way to tidy things
up really
and
kind of just to sort of uh close the
loop on stuff that you can do as you're
creating your tracks um if we combine
what we know about the fr unit repeat
and min max we can create a very useful
pattern
so if we let's remove
that
so if we say repeat
auto fill
200 pixels then what happens is grid
will have as many 200 pixel columns as
it can in the container
so that's quite neat but you can see
they're not flexible columns they're
kind of they're they're fixed we're
getting 200 pixel columns then we get a
gap on the end
um
if we
say
min max
200 pixels
refer
then we'll get as many
flexible columns as will fit with a base
size of 200 pixels they'll never get
smaller than 200 pixels they're likely
to get a bit bigger because there's that
little extra space that's getting shared
out
um
and that lets you sort of create a a
responsive pattern really without having
to use any media queries uh because
that it's just working out how many it
can put in so that's it that's a useful
little pattern and you can use that for
all sorts of interesting stuff
so that's sort of the basics of creating
um a grid uh
sort of very quickly
and so now we'll move on to placing
things on the grid using line based
placement
so grids always have lines um the lines
are horizontal and vertical as i
mentioned earlier they're indexed from
one
um and so here i've got a grid
um
we've got four columns and i'm using
grid auto rows so that my
tracks in the implicit grid will be a
minimum of 100 pixels and a maximum of
auto which means that they'll never be
smaller than 100 pixels but they can
grow to fit the contents their max is
auto and that just means that we can
kind of see those tracks to position
things onto them
so i'll take my item one here i've just
popped classes on these divs just to
make it make it nice and easy
and if you want to position things using
line based positioning
we can use grid column start and grid
column n to position things via columns
so let's start on line one
and end on line three
and you can see now that that item is is
stretching over
a couple of tracks there
um
those the the longhand properties
they're obviously fairly lengthy um
you've also got grid row start and grid
row end if you're working by rows
uh you can compress that down to a
shorthand if we just use grid column
and then use a forward slash
and then
the end line that you want to go to
so remember you're targeting lines not
the tracks um so we're going to line
three because that is the line that sort
of is after track two so you're telling
the line numbers rather than the tracks
if you want your item to start at the
first line end at the last line you can
use minus one as your last line
because as well as counting up from one
from the the start of the of the uh
layout
they count back from minus one from the
end line so you can target that or you
could go to the second last line
with -2 for example
a little note is that that only works
for the explicit grid so you can only do
the negative line numbers um with the
grid tracks that you've defined with
grid template columns and grid template
rows it doesn't work to go to the last
line say if you're just filling up a
grid with implicit rows um that way you
won't be able to target the last one
with minus one
it is an issue that's raised that we'd
quite like to be able to do that um but
i think it's because of the the
performance implication of laying
everything out and then working out
where the last line is going to be that
at the moment that doesn't work so minus
one will only go to the last line of the
explicit grid so the last line of what
you specified with grid template columns
and grid template rows
so let's say this all works in in the
same way for
for rows other than that that sort of
minus one things we've got implicit rows
here so we say grid row
one to three
so my rows are getting that height
because of the min max function um
setting them to a minimum of 100 pixels
just so we can kind of see
where we've got those rows
so that's really the basics of
um
positioning things by lines it's very
very straightforward um
you give it a start line and an end line
and
and then you can position things
wherever you want um and you'll note
that the other items just carry on
laying out via the auto placement
mechanism where grid finds a cell and
we'll talk a bit more about auto
placement next because there's a few
things that it's worth understanding
about how that works um
everything on top of
the all the other things we're going to
look at for doing positioning is
basically built on top of this grid of
lines
so you can just use line based placement
and never worry about anything else if
you don't want to
and just use this simple go from this
line to that line
if that's if that's easier so
so everything else is kind of a
you know a nice bit of syntax on top of
this this grid of lines
worth it you can overlap things you can
place things into the same cell as
another thing
um that's fine
um and then if you do that you can
control that with z and x just like
absolutely positioned items you don't
need to add position relative or
anything grid just works with z index so
if you position things into the same
cell and you want to switch their order
then you can just give it a higher z
index and that will work
so i am kind of rattling through things
today because you obviously don't have a
huge amount of time and i'll try and
pick up some questions at the end if
they're not answered by future material
but
and i'm going to try and sort of get
through a bunch of stuff
so
i want to talk a bit about auto
placement because most of the questions
i get
that where people are a bit confused
about something that grid's doing uh
they have something to do with auto
placement
and auspicious really powerful in grid
because it means that we can
you know create a grid and just then
chuck a bunch of content at it and lay
it out and there's so many patterns on
the web that are just that you know
these sort of card type layouts are
literally just
here's some stuff
you know please lay it out in a nice
kind of display
so auto placement is is what grid does
when you create a grid but you don't
position any items um and so
if no items are positioned at all then
you know we just start in the top left
if we're in english um
and
fill up the first row and then you know
carry on filling up rows which you know
if you want a basic card layout that's
that's kind of what you got there
but we can we can tweak this and we can
sort of
do some slightly different things with
with auto placement
so let's get
um the the first child perhaps surf here
and what i'm going to say with this item
is i want to start where it would
normally start which is going to be on
line one but we'll say autos if you use
auto for a line number that's going to
use its auto placement position
i'm going to say span 2
you can see now that first item has
spanned two
two rows of the grid two row tracks
if we
get our even items
and this time i'm going to spam columns
there i'm saying start where you would
normally start where auto placement
would put you but span over two column
tracks
so this is kind of a useful pattern you
know you could be targeting these items
anywhere you like
for example you could have a bunch of
images and some of them are portrayed in
some of them a landscape
and you want the landscape ones to span
two tracks so you could maybe have a
class on the ones that have landscape
images and target it that way
um you'll notice that there are gaps in
the grid when we do this
and so by default what grid layout is
doing
is it is keeping things in source order
so if you look at the source here and
i've numbered the items that makes it
easy
we've got one two three there's not
enough space here for four to fit so
it's just gone down to the next line and
then we've got five
you can modify that behavior
with grid auto
flow
set to dense
and so you can see what's happened there
is that
item number five has kind of hopped up
and filled that gap
so
what that does is it kind of takes
things out of source order
and
if you think about accessibility that
could potentially be a bit of a problem
um if you if these were say product
cards and someone was tabbing through
them
then you could end up with a rather
confusing sort of behavior where you're
sort of jumping around
the screen
so generally you need to be very very
careful
um
when messing around with things like
good auto flow and dense packing
but even just with you know with
positioning things by lines or what have
you if you start to take things away
from the board that they are in the
source
you can end up creating a very confusing
experience for people
because there's an awful lot of people
who
maybe use a screen reader but it also
can see the content on the screen
um or using the keyboard completely to
navigate
um and and in that situation you can
sort of create an odd experience the way
to test it
is a lot of dev tools now we've got um
the ability to check that the sort of
the tab order through a document
um and the other thing is just to
keyboard navigate yourself you know
put your mouse away put your trackpad
away and use your keyboard to get around
your site
and make sure that that does make sense
because for a screen reader user they're
going to have things read out to them
in source order
so the biggest issue is people who are
you know
accessing the accessing the document and
can also see the layout because it can
be very very disconnecting
um if you uh mess things around so
that's just a general warning with
with grid and lesser flexbox i mean you
can do with anything you could do with
absolute positioning as well you could
cause a mess but because we don't tend
to lay out our entire layouts with
absolute positioning it's not been as
much of a problem as it is now
and i have a second auto placement
example just because i wanted to
highlight something which tends to come
up as an issue
so i've got some items here which
are
positioned on
on my grid here
and they've all got
some sort of placement which is why
they're like this and so we've got bits
of white space
where there isn't an item
add another item
it shows up um right up here in that bit
of white space that we've left
and
that
typically is quite confusing when it
happens because you kind of expect that
auto placement will start after all of
the items that you've placed
if you mix
auto placement and
line based positioning
um
and so an auto placed item appears it
will go into the first available cell
for it
so when this causes people problems is
they've made a grid on their body
element
and then so and they've got some white
space in that as part of their layout
and then something gets injected in or
someone puts something in with the cms
or whatever
and it appears in a really weird place
and they can't understand why it got
there
it's this is going on you've got a lot
of positioned items you've just put
something in
and it's appeared in an odd place um
catches everybody out caught me out the
other day i was building an example that
just happened to use grid um i was you
know demonstrating something else and
i'm like why is that where is that thing
coming from and why it was because it
was something which i hadn't placed and
so it was
it sort of popped up into that place so
generally
if you're using auto placement use auto
placement
if you're positioning items you probably
want to position all of your items um
because otherwise you are going to get a
slightly odd odd effect
like this
and if something does appear in an odd
place in your grid layout you can be
pretty sure that's what's going on
you've got something which hasn't got
a position on your grid
so let's look at number five which is
named lines
so i really just wanted to
sort of show you an example of of naming
lines on
on the grid
um because it's a sort of a
a slightly unusual syntax um
and so this example i've i've got some
regular line based edition things but
i've also added some named lines
um
to sort of show you that
so you name lines on your grid
um by using um
a name within square brackets like this
which is
a slightly sort of unusual syntax and
the name can be pretty much anything you
want
um other than keywords that we use in
grid layout so you couldn't use say span
as a name but otherwise you can use
pretty much anything you like
so you name your lines
in the position where that line is so
this main start is essentially line one
which means that our item one
which starts at main start and finishes
at main end that's basically like doing
one minus one because i've got main end
at the end of the grid
you totally don't have to use named
lines um
as you can see i've mixed it here with
with using line numbers
there's kind of a sort of reasons why
you might want to do it i mean it might
be easier for other team members you
know if you name the lines on your grid
um and then they can just position
things against them you can have
multiple line names if you want so for
example
we could also have
um
you know call start
and
i'll end in here so you can have
multiple lines you just need to separate
them with a
with a space and then you could use
either of those line names to target
that line so you might want to do that
just to make it easier for the people to
work with your grid
if you are redefining this grid within
media queries
then if you're careful with naming lines
naming specific lines you could for
instance always have content against
line content even if line content was
you know line two in one context and
line one in another
so you can kind of use it that way to
to help make it easier to do a
responsive layout and not need to keep
track of which line things are
positioned against
so that's uh
that's kind of useful the um
the convention is to use this dash start
dash end for your start and end lines
which gives a little bit of extra
functionality that we'll we'll look at
later but
uh you don't need to so you could call
them a b c and d if you wanted um it
doesn't really matter you can call them
anything you want
but this is a convention still you'll
often see people with this
sort of name dash start and end
in their named lines
let's say you um
you absolutely don't need to use it um
i don't see it used that often i think
people it is not so common used but it's
sort of i think a lot of things in good
layout it's just like it's worth knowing
that you can do it because it might come
in useful later on so
i sort of just know that you can
i don't have time to go into it too much
today but you can have multiple lines
with the same name in which case they
act like an index of those lines
so if you named every other line
um
you know a name say call or whatever
and then you you targeted coal too that
would get the second line that was named
cole so again that's a useful
possibility it allows you to sort of
target a set of lines
um
rather than targeting the whole grid
so that's just yeah something handy to
know that that you can work with
but probably more likely what you're
going to want to use is the the concept
of named grid areas
because i think this is my favorite
thing about the grid
because this gives us a different way to
lay out our items
so what we do with grid template areas
is we define in css what our layout
looks like
as the value of the grid template areas
property
so this is my container
and i've got my four column grid here
and so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to use
grid template areas
and we're going to just do a bit of
ascii art here
which is defining each row
of the layout
each row is is between the
quotes
that's not going to do anything exciting
just yet
but then if we go down to our items
which you've each again got a class on
them
we can then place them on the grid using
the grid area property
so basically putting each of these items
into a position on the grid
so i've used the names that i defined up
here and i've given each of my items
a grid area so that's the area that it's
going to sit in
so as you can see a
repeated name
causes the item to span tracks
and
we've sort of got these different
rectangular areas they have to be
rectangular areas you can't create like
an l-shaped piece or something like that
we can't do any kind of tetris within
our ascii art at the moment
um
and you have to have a complete grid you
can see we've actually filled every cell
of the grid
now that doesn't mean you can't have
white space if you want to have white
space
then you can just use a dot
and you can actually use
a string of dots so that will help your
ascii art line up which i think is quite
nice um
you can also have multiple white spaces
in between things so if you had
different
different lengths of names um then you
can use multiple spaces to get it all
line up um
so a dot will give you white space
i mean if you kind of say if you don't
have a complete grid or you use a
t-shaped area or something like that
then essentially the whole value would
be seen as invalid and be thrown away
and you won't get a layout so
you kind of have to use use it as you
want but the nice thing about this it's
so easy to play around with your layout
here
um you know if i
want to see what my
sidebar looks like if it spans um two
rows i can just do that
as it's a very nice way to sort of play
around and experiment with layout
and it's also very easy to redefine as
you can imagine inside your media
queries because you can just if you've
named everything you can just redefine
grid template areas
to move from a two to a four column
layout or what have you
um i also think it's just really nice um
particularly if you're working in a kind
of component-based system
so you've got all of your components and
their css you can see what that looks
like looking at the css which i think is
just a really nice thing because that's
something that
css doesn't really do very well um it's
very very difficult to kind of look at
some css and figure out what on earth
it's doing
in terms of the actual layout whereas
you know with this you can actually see
right there in in that container what
its layout looks like um which i think
is
it's kind of just a really nice thing
and an unusual thing for css so if you
think about our layout methods of the
past using floats or something i mean i
mean you actually have no idea what's
going on unless you poke around in dev
tools so and it's actually very nice to
be able to see that
so yeah i use this all the time i i love
it um
before grid was even really a thing um i
started using this a prototyping just
because it's so easy to to mess about in
code with with your layouts it's um i
was using it behind a flag just to
prototype stuff because it's a nice
thing to use
so have a quick look at something that
you get when you use good air it's just
grid lines from
named areas
so we're basically going back to a
similar sort of
layout here
but i've got an extra item at the bottom
which is being placed by auto placement
so again if you've got
something laid out with with good
template areas auto-placed items are
just going to end up
um
below now
i mentioned with line based positioning
that you can position items onto the
grid using lines so you can you can
combine
um grid template areas with line based
positioning if you want so we've got our
item here
and i could layer that onto the grid
say grid column one and
red row
so that's gonna
sort of dump it layer it on top and
again that would be that would be sort
of controllable with z index you've got
your box there
um
you can also though
place it by using line names and the
line names are generated from the names
that you've given the different areas on
your grid
so we could also position this
with sd
start
and sd
start and it's against the footer isn't
it so
ft
end
this is like using your line base your
named line placement
but the named lines are being generated
by the names that we gave our areas
with dash start and dash end
appended so both for rows and columns
so so for the area hd we're going to
have hd start at the top
hd start at the bottom so that's for
rows
and for columns we've got hd start on
the left because we're in english and hd
end on the right
so you can actually use those to place
an item
into that layout
and like and so and to layer things over
i mean for example
you might want to put a close button if
this was a little dialogue panel or
something you might want to put a close
button top right well you could
you could use the lines to know that
you're always targeting that top right
area without having to use line numbers
which might change in a responsive
layout if you're changing the number of
of column tracks
so again that's a handy little thing um
which i don't see people use very often
but again it's a kind of just a useful
little bit of functionality um that you
might find handy one day it'll solve a
problem so
it's sort of handy to know you can do
that
so then we'll have a look at alignment
on the grid
so
when we start looking at all these demos
um and i think with a lot of grid demos
you know we see this
we see these are the full height columns
and content which is stretched all the
way over each grid cell or grid area
now the reason they're doing that is
because the alignment properties
by default stretch
over the full area that an item is in so
if you've got a background color on it
it fills the entire area
um
it's quite nice we spent a long time on
the web battling to have full height
columns and the default for both grid
and flexbox is you get full height
columns
the only time that doesn't happen is if
your item has an aspect ratio so that
would be something like an image
um
images
or video anything with an aspect ratio
will be aligned to start
um
both for rows and columns rather than
stretch
so we don't stretch your images by
default um if you want to stretch your
image if your image is a grid item and
you want to stretch it you absolutely
can but by default we won't do that
because that would kind of well
generally you don't want to stretch your
images out of shape
um so all of the alignment properties
are detailed in the box alignment
specification if you learned flexbox
when flexbox first came out you might
think of them as really been tied to
flexbox because they started with that
spec
but they then got themselves moved out
so that we could do alignment anywhere
in the same kind of
way so when we talk about alignment
everybody's first question is i can
never remember how whether i should be
using a line or justify
um so i'll try and explain when you
should use a line and justify
so in grid and we'll look at flexbox
later but in grid
um you use the properties that begin
with a line on the block axis so if
we're in english
which is a horizontal writing mode the
block axis is the the going from top to
bottom
um and it's the the axis of which our
blocks lay out one after the other
so on that axis we're going to use the
properties that start
with a line so that's a line content
align items align self
now a line content controls the
distribution of space between the tracks
so in this case my grid is defined by
that this little grey border
and so i've got some extra space and
i've got extra space because i'm using
pixels for my track sizing so i'm not
using a sizing that will let them
stretch to fill
the the remaining space
um so that means that i can do something
with that spare space
i could say align content space
between
and it helps if you spell correctly
so what's happened there is that the
spare space um in the block direction
has been put between the items and
you'll see that the um
these items here have got bigger and
that's because they've got a gap and so
they're getting some extra space um put
into that gap and because they span over
it
and that means they also get bigger so
that's something to be aware of with
grid
that obviously you're going to get space
between tracks that might have things
um
sort of spare spanning over them
um and so you can see you can center it
on this axis
center
it's very much like the the properties
we used to in flexbox so the same the
same sort of values you can use
and so that's distributing
the spare space so the other thing you
want to do is align the actual items
themselves so they're stretched by
default
and so you can use align items
so now instead of stretching on the
block axis to give us our full height
columns it's just they've just aligned
up to the start of that item
and we could use end
it all goes down to the end
and what align items does is it sets all
of the align self properties so we can
do those on an individual basis you
could say align self
center
that gets my first item and aligns it to
the center
so we're basically just shifting things
up and down there on the block axis
so you can then on the inline axis do
exactly the same but using justify
so if we say
justify
content
center
that moves all of the tracks there into
the center
or we could say justify content
and
and that moves all of the tracks to the
end so we're now working in the inline
direction so here we can sort of left
and right in english
now we can justify items
and so that's now justifying the item to
the end of its area
and again we've got the self property so
we can say
justify self and target one of them
let's get that one we had before and say
center to it
that's moved that one to the center
so you can see once you start doing that
things can stop looking like a grid and
this is where your ability to layer
things
sort of works because you might have an
item which is stretched all the way over
an area you position another item into
that same area
and then align it so that it goes to the
top right for example like a close
button
and this kind of means you don't
necessarily have to use so much like
absolute positioning for those things
which can be a little bit fragile you
can actually use grid itself to to move
things around
um
so
that's the line but you kind of have to
play around with them to get used to
using them i think people
find them quite confusing um dev tools
are really handy because you can kind of
see where you're moving things around
you look at the grid in dev tools and um
and just play around with them until you
get the idea but in grid it's fairly
straightforward you've got two
dimensions you've got block and in line
if you want to move things on the block
axis the properties begin with a line if
you want to move them on the inline axis
you're going to use the properties that
begin with justify and you've got two
different things to deal with you've got
the space around tracks which only works
if you've got extra space
and then you've got the item inside its
area to sort of move about
and by combining those you can do all
sorts of interesting things
so moving swiftly on um
something that is quite useful i wanted
to wrap up the grid stuff with is using
generated content with grid layout
because i think this lets you do all
sorts of interesting things again it's
solving problems that people say oh you
know how do i do this with grid
one of the things we can't do at the
moment is
style
a grid area without putting something
into it so you have to have you know
some html element in there in order to
give it a border for example um
we're looking at ways to change that in
the css working group to give people a
way to to style
um the sort of the
the gap as it were um but at the moment
that isn't possible but you can do quite
a bit of it by using generated content
because it works really nicely with grid
so
just as a quick demo of that if i
say container before
and we're just putting in an empty
string of generated content
and we'll give it a background color so
we can see it
you see there we've got essentially a
new grid item and so the generated
content works exactly the same way as
any other grid item
when you say before with generated
content what it does is it adds a first
child
it's a little bit misleading so you're
sort of saying container before you feel
that should be before the container if
it's not it's actually before the
content of the container so that's what
you get and you've also got after
so i'm just going to copy that
and if you use after
that will give you
the
last child essentially so put in a piece
of generated content um as the last
child of your container um so you've
kind of got these two extra elements
that you can play with by using
generated content um
which could be quite useful you can use
them to because obviously you can
position those you can use line based
positioning on them you can style them
up any way you want you can use them to
create borders on areas or you can use
them for you know little stylistic
touches
i have a sort of non-obvious use for
this which i like to do
so let's quickly do that so if i had a
heading up here
into my html
and then i'm going to say
i use generated content before and after
the heading
and then i'm going to give it a border
and align it
and then
i go to my h1
say display
basically creating a three column grid
and i'm going to give it a gap
so what that's giving me is nice
flexible um
sort of lines either side of my heading
um there's a ton of patterns like this
uh the nice thing about this i think
this demonstrates a couple of things
that i like to show people with grid you
don't just need to use grid for like
your main page layout you can use it on
components as well
um
you know i quite often turn
um you know little components into a
grid just so i can do this sort of thing
i can i can somehow style it up
um a lot of what i did before before i
was at google you know one of the things
i did was i had a cms product so i did
lots and lots of kind of ui little bits
of user interface um and grid's really
useful for that stuff if you get away
from thinking of it as just for your
main layout
um and yeah there's tons of little
things where you're just like oh i just
want to be able to have a nice you know
little stylistic line or something so
this is quite useful
useful pattern and it works because
basically we're saying
that center track which is where the
heading text ends up is auto sized so
we'll be big enough to fit the contents
we've talked about before
either side we've got a 1fr track and so
they will just take up as much space um
as they need
and so it'll be nice and nice and
flexible and if the heading gets bigger
those lines will just get smaller
because they're only going to take up
the space they want
so that's kind of just a
useful little
um tip and just to
have you think about grid you know
outside of
big grids and page layouts and so on um
you know the the sort of intrinsic
sizing and generated content and just
thinking of interesting ways to lay
things out it can be actually quite
useful for
so we've got half an hour left to go and
i want to go through flexbox a little
bit
um
and the reason i sort of do grid first i
think grid is actually easier to
understand in a lot of ways than flexbox
because flexbox is
kind of a bit weird
and i think we sort of see it as being a
bit weird because
when it first showed up we thought
um oh we'll use we'll use flexbox to do
grid layouts because it's better than
floats which is true um it would have
found it difficult to be worse than
floats for layout um but it wasn't never
really designed for doing
grid layouts um because what flexbox is
designed for is taking a bunch of oddly
sized things
and returning the best layout for those
things which is also something that is
impossible to do with floats really you
know it's very very difficult you have
to kind of give things percentage sizes
and push them around with floats
so i think it's time now to think about
flexbox more for what it was designed
for um so that's really what we're sort
of gonna look at here
so again
it's a value of display
so we say display flex
and we immediately get a bunch of
flexbox behavior i mean that might be
all you want to do is it's really useful
um the items display as a row they line
up at the start and they don't grow to
fill the container um what they actually
do is go to max content size if they can
so
they displays a row because the initial
value of flex direction is row
and of course with flexbox
we can
play around with the direction
of the main axis so the flex direction
property changes your main axis and we
can also do things like
reverse the flow of that main axis which
sort of switches the start and end
um just like with dense packing in grid
um don't do this if
your problem is that you've got your
items in the wrong order that change
your html
because just like with grid the
navigation order the tab order of the
content is going to be what your html is
so if you start switching things around
you're probably going to cause people
problems
where you're not going to cause problems
and you know there is reasons you might
want to use it say you've got like an
icon and a field or something and
they're not targetable you know the
icon's not targetable you just want it
to be on the other side of the field
that's probably a reasonable use of
doing row reverse you'd probably get
away with that but again test it if
you're doing that stuff um when i used
to do sort of audits of people's css
this would be the sort of thing i would
look for is the use of
row or column reverse or the order
property in flexbox um
you know if i found those that would be
a little bit of a red flag that you know
have we jumbled stuff up and it's not
always you know as i say people can use
them well
but
that's just something to kind of be
be aware of um check your tab order make
sure that you're not creating a mess for
somebody
um flexbox again works with um
the writing mode of the document so if
we happen to be using arabic
the items would start on the right and
flow
over to the left because it goes with
the document flow
and that's common with as say grid and
flexbox
were designed once we would kind of
realize that people don't just use
english on the web and so they've been
designed for
that reality um
and so which is why we don't tend to
talk about top right bottom left like we
do in other places in css we work with
um
the sort of the logical flow relative
directions
so the other thing to sort of just
remember with flexbox is rather than
thinking about block and inline because
we can do this thing of changing the the
main axis
um you tend to want to think about the
main axis and the cross axis when you're
doing stuff in flexbox so the main axis
is whatever you've set flex direction to
or by default row if you've not got a
flex direction property
and the cross axis is running across
that so if your if your main axis is row
then your cross axis is is the column
and so let's look at number two which is
wrapping flex items
so flexbox is designed essentially to be
a one-dimensional layout method and what
that means is you're controlling the row
or the column but not both at once
now you can obviously get um multi-line
flex containers um
so we do that
if we've got our container here
and we say display flex
and
the items are sort of they've sort of
gone into the these columns here now if
we want them to wrap we can use flex
wrap
and what that will do by default is just
wrap them all onto individual lines
which probably wasn't what you wanted
um so we'll look at the flex property
later but
i'm just going to
reflect spaces of 300 pixels which
basically says you know i don't want to
be smaller than 300 pixels so they end
up wrapping onto
two lines there
um and you can see really here this is
the difference between grid and flexbox
if you're in grid layout
then item four and five would be lined
up underneath item one and two and you'd
have a gap at the end
because we're in flexbox the space
distribution happens on a flex line by
line basis so and that's really what we
mean by one-dimensional even though
we've got
you know two rows here each of those
rows is treated like an individual flex
container so space distribution happens
just across the row this row down here
doesn't know about this one really so it
doesn't know to line up things
now obviously if you wanted to create a
flexbox grid and lots of people have
created a flexbox grid the way you do
that is by turning off the flexibility
of flexbox stopping this growing
behavior
and then sizing things in percentages
again just like you did with the floated
layout so it kind of becomes like floats
plus
um so when you do a flexbox grid
you're essentially fighting against the
natural way that flexbox behaves which
is why then flexbox seems a bit weird
and hard
um
because you're actually trying to sort
of force it into this this sort of grid
layout which it doesn't really suit
um
so if if if you enter the layout like
this and you're like actually i want
these item four and five to line up and
write one and two uh switch layout
methods say display grid create some
columns you know maybe use the auto fill
method that i showed you before
and use a grid layout for that component
they're very easy to switch um and
there's no tacks in switching layout
methods you know you don't have to worry
about whether you're using grid or
flexbox use the one that suits the
pattern that you're trying to build
uh is is really the key thing to
remember
so let's look at alignment in flexbox
now i think alignment is harder to
understand in flexbox and i think it's
why people often find alignment quite
confusing because we've got this
switchable axis
and we can't just say block or inline
we're actually saying well you know
what's the what's the main axis
so in flexbox when you're doing
alignment you need to think about the
main axis and the main axis is the one
that you use to flex direction
and on that axis you're
treating the items as a group
so you're sort of moving the items
around um as a group of items rather
than as individual items
um so we can have a look at that
um so we use the on on the main axis we
use the justify property
so we can say
justify
content
space between
and again just like between grid tracks
what we're doing here is we're taking
the extra space and we're sharing it out
between the items
if we say justify content
flex
end
and we take our available space and we
dump it before the items uh so
this will only work if you've got spare
space in your um
in your in your flex line if you've got
you know if your items are all packed in
and there's no extra space then justify
content won't do
anything um because it's it's it needs
the the extra space to
to share out
um
so there's no self property
when you're on the main access because
you're dealing with these items as a
group of items and you're just sharing
out space around them
if you want to do a sort of pattern and
you know it's a sort of fairly common
pattern where you've got like particular
navigation you've got sort of two groups
of navigation and you've got one lot
pushed over to the left and one lock
pushed over to the right
um
the way you do that in flexbox and it's
in the spec because this is what we
should be doing is we use auto margins
so i've just added a class to number
five there to make it nice and easy
if we say push
and if we say margin
left
auto
and that basically pushes the item over
to the right uh the reason that works is
that auto margins absorb all of the
space in their direction
um so
it's how you center a block i'm sure you
know if you've ever done it you've done
a fixed width or sort of a percentage
with layout and you've done margin left
and right auto and then the layout has
gone to the middle that's because you've
got two margins that are both trying to
get all possible space and that's just
shoving the thing into the center
if you give a flex item an auto margin
it will take all of the space and so you
get that that separation so obviously
you could put that class wherever you
wanted or you could target something
with the last child or what have you um
so if you're wondering how to deal you
know to to deal with one item
differently or a group of items
differently on the main axis
auto margin is the way to do that
um
so that sort of the the sort of basics
of of doing that um
we also have obviously the ability to
use
um
the alignment on the on the cross axis
so
in this case that's on on the block axis
so that's aligning things against each
other
um we've got a couple of things we might
want to do there
let's just
id this up so we can
the first of those
is if you've got
wrapped flex lines and spare space in
the container
um
on the cross axis you can use a line
content to deal with that space in the
same way you use justify content
so if i
give my container
a block size or some height
now you can see that the items have
stretched themselves
and i am going to say
wrap them
oh it's in the wrong place
okay if we put flex wrap on the
on the parent there we go so we've got
items here which are wrapped um and
we've got spare space you can see
they're stretching to fill all the spare
space
um so we can then use a line content and
to
distribute that space
so go i have a line because i've
basically put the space between
probably you're less likely to be using
a line content um but
it does work in the same way if you
happen to have extra space
and your
multiple lines
and then we also have a line items and a
line self
on the cross axis
so just like in grid we can use align
items
say start
that's going to align them to the start
or we can align them
to the center
now in this case we've got a sort of a
height of block size on the container um
if we didn't have that and they're all
the same sort of size then obviously
that's that's not going to do anything
because they've got nowhere to align
however if we say added
some extra text into one of these to
make one of them taller
you can kind of see there now how the
other items are central aligned against
that one
um and
just as
with um
with grid these are setting the the self
properties so if we go for that one i've
desired a class two so that one's five
and we could say align
itself
and
that one's now aligned itself to the end
um so again this gives you quite a lot
of ability to
to play around with alignment um really
useful for again small ui components
where you're wanting to you know you've
got like a label and a form field and
some little icon and quite often just um
aligning items to center we'll just line
them all up for you nicely
now the things that were just a real
pain in the past
um so quite often you know using flexbox
for
those little alignment tasks uh you know
it's it's really handy
and that's really comes to this uh this
demo here one of the very useful things
about flexbox is it allows us to
properly center items which apparently
is one of the hardest things in web
development
um
to do that we've got we've got a
container here with an item here that we
would like to center
i'm going to make it a flex container
gives me access to the alignment
properties
i can then
put it into the center um
meaning that problem is now solved um
in the future at some point uh we might
be able to do this without using display
flex
the alignment properties are specified
for block layout so just your normal
flow your regular layout of things when
they're not flex or grid
at the moment no browser has actually
implemented this because messing around
with block and inline layout is
obviously quite scary um so it's kind of
going to be something that that is is
coming i think it's probably something
that that people will look at
but there really is no tax in turning a
container into a flex container just to
do alignment um
so if all you want to do is is align the
things well that's absolutely fine um
you can you know make a deflex container
then you've got access to the alignment
properties for whatever's inside the
container to do your alignment um but
yeah at some point in the future we'll
be able to use um the alignment
properties outside of grid and flexbox
just to to align something
in inside another box i think flexbox is
quite useful in that because it shows
you that actually where you've got the
alignment properties you won't
necessarily have all of the alignment
properties you know in flexbox we don't
have all of the properties on the on the
main axis because we're dealing with
things as a group and it'll be the same
with block layout
not all of the alignment properties are
going to make sense in a block layout
context so it'll just be the ones that
do make sense will be the ones you have
access to
but yeah you know
feel free to make things flex containers
in order to align the stuff inside them
um
and it ends again it's nice that the uh
the age-old problem of not being able to
properly center things has been solved
for us
so just to finish off i wanted to look
at the the actual flex property itself
uh very quickly and
so really what we've looked at so far
with alignment is distributing space um
around the items so you've got some
spare space in your container and we're
going to sort of move the items around
by messing about without space
but you might actually want the space to
go inside the items
themselves
um see i've got my items here and one of
the items has got a lot more content
and you can see here that the default
behavior of flexbox is for the items to
go to max content so when we looked at
max content with grid
and we saw how a max content item goes
as big as it can
but no bigger you can see that that's
happening with these items
and flexbox will do that it will go to
max content if it can
and as long as your items are allowed to
shrink which they are by default
um once there's not enough room for them
to go to max content they'll start to
shrink down
into
so that they fit into the space and
they'll they'll shrink down until they
go to min content um
and so that's kind of the default
behavior of flexbox and that's
controlled by the flex properties
and the initial
values of the flex properties are flex
grow is zero flex shrink is one and flex
spaces is auto and we tend to use the
shorthand
so grow
drink
auto
so flex grow is zero the items don't
grow and you can see that because
they've only gone to max content they
haven't filled the container
um
flex shrink is one they can shrink and
we saw that when we made the container
smaller they shrunk and the flex space
is auto which again big enough to fit
the content kind of intrinsic sizing and
the flex algorithm will treat that as
going to max content if it can if not
sort of shrinking down
so that's sort of
the basics of of using um
the flex properties there so obviously
we can we can play around with those a
bit uh if you do want the items to grow
you could say flex one and you can see
now that the items have grown and
they've filled the container uh but they
haven't they haven't gone to equal sizes
it's because it's a bit like the fr unit
in grid you're sort of sharing out
whatever's left of
um in the space accord from the from the
auto basis because that's our flex basis
if you would like the items to all end
up equal
we could change auto
to zero
and again just like that fr unit we're
saying here the items have got no
intrinsic size
give them a flex basis of zero
and you get these sort of equally sized
um items so that's really the sort of
two things you might want to sort of
understand about flex basis you can give
a flex basis of a lengthy unit which is
what we were doing to force things to
wrap
if you want items to
say grow from 200 pixels so they're
never going to get smaller than 200
pixels and then they're going to wrap
onto another line you might want to give
a larger flex basis
um
but most of the time with flexbox you
can use sort of these default values for
the flex properties you don't even need
to remember
fletch grove lecturing complex basis
you can remember the in these sort of
default shorthands um
so
those are
flex initial
that's your initial advice you probably
wouldn't need to set this unless you
were setting it back to it for some
reason um
because this is just the initial values
so the things um can
they they do shrink they don't grow
and their flex basis is auto
if you say flex
auto
that gives you
shrinking so flex shrink is one
flex grow is once the items can grow and
their flex basis is auto
if you say flex
none
you get fully inflexible flex items so
their flex shrink value is set to zero
they're not allowed to shrink
um
you might want to do this if you are
just using flexbox for the alignment
properties you're saying display flexes
you want to turn on the ability to use
the alignment properties but you don't
want any other flexible behavior to
start happening you might want to use
flex one that might solve your problem i
don't think i've ever used it in
production but it's there if you need to
use it
um and then the other thing is to use
and this is what all the tutorials did
when flex spots first came out and
confused everybody flex one
is basically setting the flex grow um to
zero and uh the flex base is to zero and
flex grow to whatever you put here so
if we have an item
right class and if we say
because the flex
basis is zero
um item five with our class of five and
which has flex two is going to be two
times the size of the other items
because
you're basically setting the the flex
growth factor to being um
two rather than one the others have all
got one
um so when you use flex one two whatever
you're setting the flex space to zero so
you get that consistent
um
you know sharing out of of of content
um whereas if you use flex auto which is
the default
then flexbox looks at the max content
size and the bin content size and
figures out you know how much um
space to give each of the items um which
i think is kind of the killer feature of
flexbox it's kind of what it's for that
ability to just say hey browser here's
this bunch of things please give them a
reasonable layout don't squash a big
thing into a tiny box or leave loads of
space around um this small thing um and
so
really sort of you're kind of tweaking
that layout basically when you're using
flexbox
and i think if you are doing something
like
setting widths on all of your flex items
or setting a specific flex basis you
know you're doing lots of classes to
target individual items you're probably
going to have an easier time using grid
and
you don't need to think of grid
as just being
um
just just being for like you know
two-dimensional things you can use grid
like i did for the heading for a
one-dimensional thing just because it
gives you access to a bunch of stuff
um so i think if i was to leave you with
anything is to think of these layout
methods as giving you access
to a bunch of interesting things um that
you can then do with them rather than
thinking of them strictly as
you know grid especially macro layouts
and and flex boxes for little ui
elements you know use whichever one
works the best use whichever one gives
you the access to the tools that you
need to create the patterns that you
want
and don't be afraid to play around and
switch what you're doing if it's not
working out see if the other one will
work better for you
so that's kind of what i've got for you
today i know it has been um
a super fly through all of this stuff um
i hope some of that's been handy and
that you learned little bits and pieces
that maybe you didn't know before
um
the the discord channel is open i think
until the the end of maybe the end of
the month or so there is a css channel
there i know that i i've been in there
and uno and adam from google have been
in there as well talking about layout
stuff so you're always very welcome to
go and ask questions there maybe they're
a little bit more
complex than some of the stuff we've
covered here please use that
you know take advantage of of the the
knowledge that that we've got here and
that we're sharing
um
and i'll have a quick look through um
questions and since anything i can
quickly answer um
let's just scroll up to the top here
um right so there's someone here says um
name clients is the best practice to use
areas versus line numbers it is
absolutely up to you um so basically the
css working group makes css and we
create things that we think will solve a
wide variety of use cases but
other than the occasional accessibility
tip um
there's not really a good or bad
practice here it's very much what you
want to be doing what i would say and
having looked at quite a lot of people's
css over the years
um
choose something and use that decide on
how you're going to use something like
grid because what you don't want is you
know some people on your team using good
template areas some people naming lines
and then everyone's doing something
different you can end up with a mess so
i think
defining what you want to use is the
important thing um there's no real
difference um in terms of performance
anything else which ones there's no good
or bad practice it's more
you know what works well for your team
um
so
we've got a question about ie not
supporting grid
if you're still having to support ie at
this point i'm really sorry for you i
know some people do need to support ie
um feature queries i think somebody else
in the chat mentioned you can use you
know at supports you use that supports
display grid you can create a simpler
layout for
ie browsers and and then use
grid layout as a progressive enhancement
um
i mean hopefully you're not having to
build new things right now for
for ia um it is kind of going away um
and all you know all modern browsers
support all the stuff i've shown today
has you know fantastic browser support
you know none of this stuff is is
cutting edge at this point
um i.e really is people who've got to
support a you know i know i know some
people are still having support ie um
and it's it's it's an unfortunate thing
um
but feature queries are probably the
best way to to deal with that if you're
wanting to introduce components laid out
with grid into something which has to
support ie because remember that support
is
support isn't looks the same and i think
if you're dealing with internet explorer
at this point then there is so much
people using internet explorer are going
to be seeing such a mess on the web
they're going to be very happy if they
can just read your content and and you
know you're not doing anything that
makes it hard for them to use
so i think that you know use giving them
a simpler layout and then using feature
queries to
enhance that layout is probably a good
way forward
and if you are just adding things into
um a layout that needs to support ie
that's probably the way to go um
and yeah you know feature queries are
really for anything new that appears on
the web now you can use feature queries
to detect it and to
to provide fallbacks um if it's going to
be a problem
and we are really up on time as i say if
you've got specific questions you've got
a bit of code you want me to look at and
do stick them into the discord as i say
um we got had quite a nice chat in there
after the last workshop so you know do
use that and say i'm not the only person
who has got knowledge on css answering
their you know and adam have got a ton
of knowledge on on creating cool stuff
so so do come and use the discord i hope
this has been handy um i'm rachel andrew
i'm at rachel andrew on twitter if you
want to follow me there i do talk about
css stuff as well as cats so you can
follow me there and yeah enjoy the rest
of your day i hope this has been